So I hope it's clear that the aggregation framework is
designed to allow you to create a data processing pipeline, as
we've seen several times. Now, you can include as many
stages as you need in order to achieve a goal. For
each stage, you just need to consider what input that
stage needs to receive and what output it needs to produce.
Now, what I want to talk about here, is the fact that
many tasks require us to use more than one stage with
the same operator. For example, we frequently need multiple
group stages, in order to achieve our goal. So, let's
look at another example. This time I really want you
to consider each stage individually and just think about the
inputs and outputs. We're going to do a tweak
on our original question of user mentions. And this time
we're going to look at who has mentioned the most
unique users. So, in the same way that we looked
at unique hashtags just a minute ago, now
we're going to, look at modifying this pipeline
so that we're only counting mentions of users
not already accounted for in our grouping. So
here's the code for this. We have our same unwind stage as before, but the group
stage is different, and you'll notice that there's
another unwind stage here and another group stage here.
In the first group stage, what we're doing is,
aggregating still on the user's screen name but, rather
than simply summing up all of the documents that
this group stage received in order to calculate all the
user mentions, because of course unwind is going to generate
one document for every user mention. Instead what we're
going to do here is use the addToSet operator
that we looked at just a couple minutes ago. Now,
what we're paying attention to here is the
screen name for the user that was actually
mentioned in the tweet. So we're accumulating an
array here in this group stage of a unique
set of users mentioned in tweets produced by
this user, or by each user. Okay, but that
doesn't get us what we want, because again
remember our question is, who has mentioned the most
unique users? Okay, so to this point, all we
have is a list of unique users. We haven't counted
them yet. Now in order to do that, what we're
going to need to do is think about what's the
output from this group stage? Well, the output is
going to be exactly what we defined here as the
structure of documents coming out of this. All documents will
have an underscore id field. Which will be the username
that forms the basis for the grouping that
that document represents. And there will be this
mset field, our mentions set. Okay? So this
stage here, will receive documents with an underscore
id field and an mset field. So, what that means is that we can use unwind
again here, and produce one document for every
item in this array. And again remember this is
going to be an array of unique elements because we used the addToSet operator to
produce it. So unwind then will generate one document for every item found, in
the mset field where each document in its input. So this stage then,
will unwind this array of unique user mentions and pass
those along to this second group stage. And it's this group stage where
we end up calculating the count that we want.
So instead of just counting all user mentions as we
did before, here, instead what we're going to do,
is now count those unique mentions that get passed along
to us here after unwinding the mset array. Okay?
So the documents then to be passed along from this
second group stage to sort are going to contain an
id. This is just a, copying over essentially of the
id that we got as input to this stage,
which, is going to be the id that is produced
here at this stage. And then we're simply counting
how many documents did I receive that have that id?
Or how many unique user mentions did I receive
for this specific user? Okay? Then we're simply going to
sort based on the count field, in descending order as
we've been doing through most of our examples. And, finally,
here I'm going to limit it to ten so we can actually see what the
counts are for unique user mentions for the
top ten tweeters. Okay. So, let's run this.
Okay. So, we can see the names of the users,
and their respective number of unique user mentions throughout this collection.